sie sind mit einer Rakete von SpaceX
Elon Musk zu iss geflogen ganz genau als
Europäer bin ich mal per Anhalter durch
die Galaxis unterwegs
oder mit Space Shuttle und jetzt ist es
halt mit der amerikanischen
kommerziellen Raumfahrt Industrie
möglich weil wir Europäer uns weil wir
es nicht riskieren oder uns nicht selbst
engagieren eine eigene europäische
Rakete zu entwickeln die Europäer ins
All fliegen kann und das ist der Moment
ne genau das ist der Moment beim
Einsteigen bevor es losgehen und das war
am 11 November 21 sind ganz links zu
sehen glaube ich ne ganz ganz genau ja
genau
sie mit drei Amerikanern ne oder hätten
sich träumen lassen ich meine auf sowas
arbeitet man ja lange hin und am Ende
fliegen sie nicht mit einer Ariane
sondern sie fliegen mit einer Rakete von
SpaceX an Privatflugzeug mit einer
gebrauchten Rakete die war ja schon mal
geflogen die ist danach dann noch mal
gel hat dann den Satelliten hochgebracht
ist dann noch mal gelandet und nach
einem halben Jahr als meine Kollegin
Samantha Christopher das die aus Italien
hochgebracht immer mit derselben
nein die Fliegen standardmäßig bis zu 15
Mal aber jetzt wird schon daran
gearbeitet die noch öfter zu fliegen und
die Kapsel mit der ich oben war das war
eine ganz neue Kapsel die ist jetzt
schon zum dritten Mal wieder oben ist
gerade auch wieder mal und die gehört
einem Milliardär aus Kalifornien im
aktuellen reichsten Menschen dieses Jahr
und die Fachwelt hat lange gesagt das
geht nicht Raketen wieder zu landen
wieder zu verwenden und da sind wir bei
dem Thema natürlich wir haben bei vielen
der Fragestellung noch keine Antworten
aber es wird Menschen geben die diese
Antworten finden auch auf zukünftige
Frage stellen ich glaube wir haben sogar
ein paar Bilder vorbereitet vielleicht
können wir das mal zeigen das war ja
spektakulär damals ne der Moment in dem
Maske dann zum ersten Mal gezeigt hat
das geht wir können einfach wieder
landen vorher war die Situation ja du
fliegst quasi mit der 747 nach New York
bist du weg
und dann kaufst du eine neue genau und
jetzt kommen wir zurück und wir zeigen
das einmal ganz kurz was war technisch
Herr Mauer daran die große
Herausforderung das zu machen ja die die
Hauptstufe in der 70% des Wertes der
Rakete liegen die wieder zu landen also
das ist ja eine Stufe die es auf über
100 km Höhe und die dann sehen das ist
das Starship das wieder landet das ist
sozusagen die Weiterentwicklung wir sind
jetzt gerade im Übergang zwischen Falke
9 und Starship 9 mit einer Dragon Kapsel
mit der ich geflogen bin da passen vier
Astronauten rein und dieses Starship
Rakete könnten bis zu 100 Astronauten
reinpassen
ich würde mal sagen wir sind am Übergang
zwischen Tesla fliegen was wir momentan
machen hinter einem Airbus A320 und das
wird natürlich den Transport von Fracht
deutlich günstiger gestalten
diese vier Leute drin sondern da sitzen
dann 200 oder 100 100 aber gut am Anfang
wird erstmal nur Fracht hochgebracht
klar könnte die ganze Raumstation mit
zwei Raketenstart hochbringen das heißt
wir haben 21 Jahre gebraucht um die
Raumstation aufzubauen mit vielen vielen
space Stars und das wäre jetzt in
Zukunft mit zwei Staats möglich
weil ein Privatmann sich das überlegt
hat wie ist das möglich
das Starten das nicht können und an
privater
Mann von dem die einen sagen der obere
Teil seines Körpers ist Genie und dann
darunter ist so ein bisschen mit life
crisis und alles mögliche und
schwieriger Charakter und so weiter
sollte man solchen Leuten das All
überlassen solche Themen solche Dinge
die Frage ja schon versucht vorsichtig
zu tun sehr schön sehr sehr schön also
ich fühle mich bei solchen Fragen immer
an den Film Moonraker erinnert und James
Bond wieder dann da oben landet wieder
dann der Oma so eine Raumstation kommt
du musst irgendein irgend so eine
Übelkeit der das Handwerk legen genau
und ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
bestürzend dass man im Weltall fast
sowas hat wie eine Diktatur während also
hier unten auf der Erde die Demokratien
versuchen irgendwie den Kopf über Wasser
zu halten hat man es bei so einer Firma
dann wirklich ja mit jemand zu tun der
technologisch das völlig durchdrückt der
natürlich auch eine ganze Truppe von
ganz hervorragenden
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hat die in dem
Gebiet einfach absolute Spitzenklasse
sind und der lässt sie konvergent also
wirklich zusammenlaufen und an diesem
Projekt arbeiten viele Herausforderungen
die man vielleicht den
Anführungsstrichen im im öffentlichen
öffentlich rechtlichen sozusagen hat die
haben die nicht das heißt die sind
einfach nur dazu bauen und das ist
natürlich schon sehr beeindrucken wenn
man das sieht anders finde ich auch muss
ich aber hier dann schon mal an der
Stelle gerade wenn ich dann höre wir
beschleunigen einen technologischen
Vorgang doch mal wieder Wasser in zwei
in den Wein gießen denn wir haben ja
schon erlebt das beschleunigungsprozesse
in Technologien ganz erhebliche Schäden
anrichten können und wenn Paketen die
von hier unten starten naja ich denke
daran dass wir in den Jahren von 1960
bis heute von 310 Parts per million CO2
auf 420 Parts bei Medien CO2 gegangen
sind alleine nur durch den
technologische Beschleunigung in den
letzten 30 Jahren insbesondere das eben
zum Beispiel das fliegende Massen mit
einem Massenerscheinung geworden ist das
Kommunikation eine Massener also vieles
von dem was wir heute ja auch als
wichtigen wichtigen Bestandteil des
modernen Lebens empfinden hat hat seine
hat seine Kosten und der der Flug ins
Weltall ist momentan mit denen mit den
Treibstoffen die verwendet werden extrem
klimaschädlich also das ist ein
deutlicher Unterschied pro Passagier was
der CO2 was den CO2
dass da hundert Passagiere in so einer
Rakete drin sind und dass das vor allen
Dingen umständlich mehr und mehr
Infrastruktur ins allzu bringen in einer
Form sich vervielfältigt wie wir das
heute bei den bei dem Phänomen sagen wir
mal Massentourismus sehen wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass wir das wirklich ins
Weltall tragen mit denen mit den Stoffen
die momentan haben würde das ganze
erheblichen Teil zur Klimaerwärmung
beitragen das können wir eigentlich nach
den Erfahrungen die wir mit dem
beschleunigungsprozessen der letzten 50
Jahre haben eigentlich nicht wollen das
können wir so nicht weitermachen und
deshalb hat die
Raumfahrt groß macht Luxemburg ja ja im
August 2 2017 als erstes europäisches
Land dann Weltraum Gesetz verabschiedet
das klingt lustig und es ist es
irgendwie auch
was wird da geregelt vor lauter also in
erster Linie geht es darum natürlich
auch um den Bergbau im Weltraum
letztendlich geht's darum dass man jetzt
sehen kann Luxemburg hat angefangen
andere Staaten haben schon hinterher
gezogen
aber das tatsächlich wirklich man
versucht dabei
die nationalen Weltraumindustrie in der
möglichst gute Ausgangslage zu bringen
dass man den rechtlichen Rahmen in den
Ländern schafft um die
weltraumindustrien also die new space
economy zu fördern weil das ist ein
immenser Wachstumsmarkt Herr lash hat es
ja schon angesprochen es geht um
Infrastruktur um Dienste digital
vernetzte Gesellschaften sind heute in
so einem großen Maß davon abhängig dass
man hier wirklich eine große
gewinnmarsche erwarten kann und
vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz zurück was
sehr leicht auch gesagt hat und ihre
Eingangsfrage was man wieso ein Ellen
macht das überhaupt kann weil ganz
ehrlich im Vergleich zu dem ersten Mond
Rennen zu dem ersten space age sich die
Charakteristika die Rahmenbedingungen
der weltraumnutzung wirklich verändert
haben früher war es ein staatliches
Monopol was das technische Know-how
angeht was Produktionskosten angeht das
hat sich mehr und mehr Richtung
Industrie private Akteure vergeben und
gerade in den USA hat das da in
Paradigmenwechsel gegeben dass man eben
gesagt hat der kommerzielle Sektor soll
doch bitte diese payloads in den
Weltraum schaffen oder Astronauten nach
oben also das ist eine politisch
gewollte oder sag mal so vielleicht
waren die Folgen nicht ganz absehbar
aber das ist ein politischen Kontext
gesetzt worden dass ich einfach die
Rahmenbedingungen dermaßen verändert
haben dass es jemanden wie ein Maske
ermöglicht diese verrückten Dinge zum
Teil zu tun wie diskutieren Sie das
genau also ich würde ganz ganz zu dem
Thema Luxemburg weil sie das so
eingeführt haben noch mal in wollen
wir hatten ja eben angesprochen wo kann
man im Weltraum Geld verdienen und dann
hat man das Thema mit Energieerzeugung
angefangen aber eigentlich fängt man in
der Telekommunikation an der
Telekommunikation ist es so jeder Euro
der dort investiert wird der erzeugt 20
€ gewinnen und der Weltmarktführer 1 zu
20 1 zu 20 ein toller Hebel das meine
Rendite genau ja jetzt überlegen Sie wo
der Weltmarktführer sitzt eine
Telekommunikation in Luxemburg
deswegen sind die Luxemburger
also verschiedene Firmen sind das die
ist der Name jetzt entfallen aber die
sitzen in Luxemburg sitzen dort und es
sind Weltmarktführer in
Telekommunikation
die ersten die investiert haben in
dieses
Luxemburger oder das ist eine
Luxemburger Firma die hat über 700
Satelliten im All und verdienen
ordentlich Geld damit und deswegen ist
in Luxemburg auch bekannt das Weltraum
in Wachstumsmarkt ist deswegen sage ich
Raumfahrt groß macht Luxemburg
stationären Satelliten
Kommunikationsbereich das ist ja ich sag
mal die Technologie die ist auch
weiterhin geben wird aber das sind ja
geostationäre Satelliten die auf einem
Orbit unterwegs sind 36.000 km Höhe und
quasi ortsfesten mit der Erde rotieren
das heißt ich kann im Grunde gewisse
Bereiche links und rechts nördlich
südlich vom Äquator erreichen die
Polkappen nicht ich habe keine globale
Abdeckung und ich habe hohe Latenzzeiten
weil das laufzeitsignal muss zum
Satelliten hoch und wiederholt wie lange
dauert das 36 Kilometer ist 36.000
36.000 km 36.000 km
wenn sie im Sommer vielleicht ein
Fußballspiel schauen im Fernsehen und
die Tür offen haben und das Tor beim
Nachbarn schon früher fällt weil der ist
auf dem Radio hört und im Fernsehbild
haben sie es deutlich zeitversetzt das
ist diese Latenz okay im Grunde spürbar
da ist wenn sie mit einem geostation in
den Satelliten arbeiten und tatsächlich
hat sich Luxemburg sehr früh schon auf
dieses Thema gesetzt und deswegen war es
ganz nah liegen dass ich Luxemburg sich
auch wieder auf die zukünftigen Themen
setzen aber heute findet
Satellitenkommunikation ja insbesondere
auch über die sogenannten lovers Orbits
gestanden sind diese
satellitenkonstellation wie auch
Starling die relativ nah sozusagen
unterwegs
ist definiert im Grunde als ein Band
zwischen 100 km oder
damit beginnt bis naja 2000 Kilometer
plus minus okay und ihr wurde natürlich
dann sind sie geflogen 400 Kilometer
fliegen wir und diese stalings die sind
dann 500 600 Nexus in Ordnung okay das
ist richtig was los da oben alles
richtig
wie viele Satelliten hat allein Elon
Musk Darling
über 5.000 mehr als die Hälfte aller
Aktiven Satelliten gehören Elon Musk und
der plant 40.000
40.000
[Gelächter]
Europa hier aktiver werden weil es
werden momentan Fakten geschaffen ja
dadurch dass einfach Satelliten
hingebracht werden und die Regeln sind
noch nicht da mein vergleichen mit
deinem Flugzeug wenn sie dann Flugzeug
sitzen und zwei Flugzeuge haben einen
Kollisionskurs dann können Sie darauf
vertrauen dass der Pilot in jedem
Flugzeug weiß wie er auszu genau bei
Satelliten gibt es diese Regeln noch
nicht da gilt einfach der Wilde Westen
was heißt das wer zuerst zuckt verliert
oder so also
in der Geschwindigkeit ja wie schnell
also es kommt immer auf den Orbit an
also wenn in unserer Höhen 400 Kilometer
Höhe fliegen wir mit 28.000 Kilometern
pro Stunde das heißt sie sehen nicht
dass da was auf sie zukommt er genau
wenn sie davon das heißt jedes winzige
Teil wird zu einem mörderischen Geschoss
heißt das genau ganz genau und das kann
nur vom Boden aus kontrolliert werden
überwacht werden mit radarinstrumenten
das liegt beim amerikanischen Militär
und die geben ihre Informationen weiter
an die verschiedenen Satelliten
Betreiber und dann müssen die
untereinander kommunizieren und sagen
okay wir haben deine potenzielle
Kollision ich denke ihr solltet
ausweichen wenn sie sagen nee ihr
solltet ausweichen dann muss man sowas
vor wenn man da oben sitzt also je mehr
oben fliegt desto öfter kann das
Vorkommen und wir sind jetzt eigentlich
am Übergang mit diesem Konstellationen
dass das nur noch mit künstlicher
Intelligenz dann autonom geregelt werden
kann weil jedes Mal wenn ich ausweiche
verbrenne nicht Treibstoff das reduziert
die Lebensdauer meines Satelliten ist
also aktiv Geld was ich verliere und
deswegen denke ich nicht ich weiß nicht
aus weil der andere sollte ausreichend
ich war zuerst hier und ähm damals
gesehen ne was passiert ja
genau aber da würde ich doch als
Investor wäre ich doch hoch beunruhigt
wenn da oben so eine wahnsinnig ist eine
gute Frage kommt drauf an ob sie ins
Darling wegwerfsatellit haben oder ob es
ein ganz extrem hochwertig
Satelliten haben der mehrere Jahre lang
in den Forschung war eine Entwicklung
war und der sozusagen ja enorm teuer ist
dann bis dahin kostet um die 300 000 $
ist das richtig ungefähr sowas kommt auf
die Generation an ob er dann auch mit
Laser Terminals sich mit anderen
Satelliten vernetzen kann aus der
Konstellation oder nicht aber wir reden
über solche Größenordnungen plus ein
bisschen Richtung Millionen aber
deutlich günstiger als früher ist viel
gerade die Vokabel wegwerfen Satellit ja
also was heißt das ja also dieses
Satelliten werden Masse hergestellt und
man nimmt aktiv im Kauf dass wenn ein
Satellit nicht funktioniert das er dann
sozusagen wieder einsetzen die
Atmosphäre verglüht und die anderen man
hat genügender
schon übrig wenn der verglüht ist er weg
genau das dauert auch ein paar Jahre bis
eben so ein Satellit dann tatsächlich
aus seiner Bahn in die Erdanziehung
wieder hineinkommt und tatsächlich
verglüht je nachdem was die Orbit Höhe
ist aber von 5 bis 20 Jahren aber wenn
man das alles dann kaputt gemacht hat
dann muss man auf einen anderen
Himmelskörper um da wieder die Rohstoffe
abzugreifen wird mir die Technik baut
die bei uns irgendwie im Weltall
und genau deshalb habe ich eingangs
schon gesagt auch als Unternehmer der
anderen nachhaltiges Business denken
möchte mache ich mir Sorgen wegen dieser
wild westmethode weil ich verderbe mir
ganze noch Orbits indem ich diesen
Weltraum Schrott produziert ja ja ja
meine wer soll denn da noch durchfliegen
sie nicht
ja wir fliegen dadurch
ja also ich meine das jetzt eine
Animation das ist eine Animation sich
das ungefähr so vorstellen ja gut ich
meine es natürlich der Weltraum ist sehr
sehr groß und die Abstände sind
natürlich schon größer aber wir können
vom Boden aus nur weltraumsportteile
vermessen die 10 cm oder größer sind und
wenn wir jetzt einen Start machen zur
Raumstation und dann werden wir
natürlich einen Korrektur wählen der
frei ist von Weltraumschrott oder auch
wenn wir auf der Raumstation sind und es
gibt Kollisionskurs da müssen wir in
ausweichmann überfliegen wenn wir
genügend Zeit haben auszuweichen und ähm
vier Tage nach meinem Start und darauf
wollte ich gerade hinaus die Russen ne
genau haben was gemacht genau also wir
sind nachts geweckt worden und es ist
ein Satellit ist auseinander gebrochen
und wir ähm viele viele Teile und wir
müssen jetzt gucken dass wir uns in
Sicherheit bringen also es war zu kurz
zum auszuweichen man wusste nicht wo
diese drümmerteile hin deswegen es war
in knapp 100 km über uns und wir hatten
vier Stunden zwei Stunden Zeit uns
vorzubereiten bevor wir in dieses
Trümmerfeld hinein geflogen was heißt
vorbereitet in dem Zusammenhang ja alle
lobendicht machen auf der Raumstation
und sozusagen dann uns in unsere Kapsel
zurückziehen und Daumen drücken es war
so ein bisschen wie der Beginn von dem
Film gravity
genau dann wird das durchgehen das ist
also wir können gewisse Teilchen
abfangen
1 cm aber alles was größer ist wird ein
Loch rein schlagen und deswegen haben
wir alle Schotten dicht gemacht wenn wir
dann nur ein Modul verlieren dann wäre
der Rest der Station kann man eigentlich
sowas vorausrechnen ähm ab wie viel
Teilen in dieser Weltraum Schrotthaufen
wird es kritisch also gibt's da
Instabilitäten die irgendwie auftreten
ist also es gibt der Kessler hat das
abgeschätzt ich glaube in den 80er
Jahren und ist eine Anzahl wenn die
überschritten ist dann ist sozusagen der
Weltraum für keinen mehr zugänglich dann
ist da und wie weit sind wir davon
entfernt jetzt prozentual Gefühl das
kann man nicht sagen also ich kann es
nicht sagen aber es gibt Fachleute die
kessler-syndrom
das sozusagen
durch eine Kollision kaskadenartig eine
Kettenreaktion folgt weil diese
weltraumschrottteilchen kann man ja
nicht kontrollieren in den 80ern
berechnet
da war auf jeden Fall deutlich weniger
Zeug da oben da will ich hinaus und
gilt sie sehr Rechnung noch fragt nur
für einen Freund
ja ich glaube dass ich die Dynamik
inzwischen durch Elon Musk und weitere
Akteure noch weiter verstärkt doch
demnächst wie viel 40.000
aber irgendwann sind sie da und ich lass
dieser Tage dass ich meine Maske ist ja
nicht der einzige der auf Daten
angewiesen ist es gibt das Unternehmen
in Sachen Daten Alphabet Google mit
anderen Worten die bauen das doch auch
auf
betreiben dieselbe auch Satelliten ja
also Amazon möchte die Creeper
Konstellation hochbringen Eser die
ist eine andere Konstellation die heißt
Creeper also ist nur ein Name ja ich
schon klar lass uns das einmal kurz
durchgehen weil es interessant amazon
bringt wie viele Satelliten nicht die
Anzahl weiß ich nicht aber auch eine
Konstellation was zu machen
wahrscheinlich ein Konkurrenz zu
Starling zu sein ja also und dann die
Europäische Union was möchte es Iris
squared Konstellation hochbringen also
wir machen das jetzt auch aber eine
geringe Anzahl von ja ungefähr 160
Satelliten nicht vergessen das Projekt
was tatsächlich auch ich mal gestartet
habe 2014 500 600 Satelliten jetzt ins
All bringen wird
ohne Konstellation es sind bis zu 100000
Satelliten geplant und beantragt
also was ich ja interessant finde ist
wir reden auf der einen Seite über die
dringende Regulation des Weltalls durch
menschengemachte Gesetze vergessen aber
ganz offensichtlich wie wir gerade sehen
die Naturgesetze die er da oben eine
ganz besondere Rolle spielen weil der
Weltraum ist leer das heißt es gibt
keine Reibung deshalb sind wir schon mal
raus wir können also die Bewegung von
Teilchen extrem gut Voraus berechnen
wenn es sich nicht um kleine
trümmerwolken handelt die total dadurch
einander fliegen also das heißt wir
können eigentlich ziemlich genau
berechnen und deswegen ist Weltraumfahrt
der überhaupt nur möglich weil dort oben
Reibungseffekte erstmal keine Rolle
spielen deswegen gemacht die Planeten so
gut berechnen aber das wird dann in der
technologischen Expansion dann schon
wieder so tun als könnten wir diese
Naturgesetze sozusagen bis zum Limit
pushen oder drüber hinausgehen dass
erinnert schon wieder daran wie wir hier
auf der Erde damit umgehen dass wir hier
eben auch die Naturgesetze komplett
ignorieren und sagen kommt das wird
schon irgendwie werden
die perfekte Überleitung weil das
tatsächlich was ja momentan auf der Erde
beobachten können diese geopolitische
Konfliktsituationen vornehmlich zwischen
den USA und China das spiegelt sich auch
im Weltraum wieder und das natürlich
beispielsweise jetzt diese Art von
Satelliten Netzwerken diese
mega-konstellation China zieht genauso
nach ich glaube mit 13.000 Satelliten
also das ist 10.000
kommen auch auf jeden Fall ganz genau
also Weltraum natürlich Faszination
gleichzeitig sind wir natürlich
unglaublich abhängig heutzutage von
diesen Satelliten gestützten Diensten
die angeboten werden und dadurch ist
Weltraum natürlich auch möglich ein
Mittel der Machtprojektion noch mal ganz
kurz dieser Satellit dieser russische
Satellit sie haben gesagt er ist
auseinander gebrochen
uns anfangs nicht mitgeteilt genau
warum ja das war eine klare
Machtdemonstration meiner Meinung nach
Russland hat den Satelliten abgeschossen
um zu zeigen dass es abschießen können
das gleiche hat von ein paar Jahren
schon mal Indien gemacht und dann hieß
es wir mussten den abschießen um zu
zeigen wissen dass wir eine Weltraum
Supermacht sind china hat schon
Satelliten abgeschossen die USA haben
Satelliten abgeschossen das heißt macht
man sowas rein technisch da wird man
Rakete hoch in den Weltraum geschossen
auf einen Satelliten und dann trifft er
uns
drunter fällt geht's runter oben
aber dieser letzte völkerrechtlich auch
das
den anderen triffst aus Versehen hast du
plötzlich genau das ist halt eine
Weltraum Waffe dann aber wir sehen der
Weltraum ist so wichtig geworden auch
für die Militär ist so wichtig geworden
weil die ganzen Augen oder Beobachter
die wir oben alle haben das ist halt
einfach entscheidend für die Situation
auf der Erde ja also sind nicht nur die
Telekommunikation es sind die
Erdbeobachtungssatelliten übrigens für
den Klimawandel kommen 95% der Daten von
den erdbeobachtungsleiter die Frage was
passiert ne
nicht nur die Ausdehnung sogar die dicke
ne wird alles aus dem allgemein gemessen
genau auch nach wenn es Krisen gibt
Erdbeben gibt oder Überschwemmungen dann
hat man halt durch diese
Erdbeobachtungssatelliten hat man die
aktuellen Daten und Informationen also
ganz ganz wichtig dann auch für die
krisengriffen dann haben wir die
Navigationssatelliten und Europa hat
hier auch das modernste
Navigationssystem der Welt Galileo das
ist nicht nur zum Navigieren mit dem
Handy wenn man irgendwo rumfährt sondern
auch das Zeitsignal ist so hoch präzise
das nutzt man auch in der Industrie zum
Schalten und Steuern von Energienetzen
oder auch Börsenkurse und so weiter und
so fort
genau das ist normal
und wenn wir jetzt einmal uns einen Tag
vorstellen würden ohne Satelliten dann
würden wir unseren Alltag nicht mehr
wiedererkennen von daher ist es so
wichtig
dann alles weg können das einmal ganz
kurz mal paar roter beschäftigt sich
auch damit was wäre dann weg es geht los
mit Wetterbericht wir haben Maurer
gesagt hatte wie komme ich heute zur
Sendung es geht darum dass ich
beispielsweise den internationalen
Personen und Warenverkehr Transport so
nicht mehr regeln könnte es geht darum
wenn ich beispielsweise Aktien kaufen
würde da geht es um diesen Zeitstempel
der ausgestellt werden muss sie könnten
vermutlich auch nicht mehr Geld von
Ihrem Bankkonto abheben weil es da auch
diese zeitstempelung braucht diesen
Abgleich zwischen Ort und Zeit also wir
sind heutzutage in einem erheblichen
Maße wirklich von Weltraumtechnologie
abhängig und der Maurer hat das gesagt
da kann ich jedem nur dieses Video von
der deutschen Luft und Raumfahrt Agentur
empfehlen die allen gezeigt haben was
passiert wenn man einen Tag den Weltraum
ausschalten würde und das wäre ziemlich
duster es kommt Charakter schon sagt
Duster ist das nicht na ja es ist
natürlich eine kritische Infrastruktur
wir haben uns in diese völlige
Abhängigkeit gegeben und müssen jetzt
und da kann ich euch allen nur zustimmen
natürlich als Europäer müssen wir uns
dringend darum kümmern dass wir
wenigstens in der Lage sind unsere
eigenen Infrastruktur zu schützen wenn
es irgendwie geht also auch die
Kontrolle über die eigene Infrastruktur
zu haben das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig
wenn man wenn man einmal diesen Weg
gegangen ist dann ist es muss man eben
bei A sagt muss dann im Grunde genommen
auch B sagen und da fehlen dann schon
die entsprechenden europäischen sagen
wir mal richtigen Schritte die
Konsequenz sind das sind die anderen
Länder deutlich konsequenter weil sie
für ihre zukünftige Rolle natürlich auch
offenbar eine ganz andere Strategie
haben was den Europäern oft fehlt ist
eine klare Strategie dass sie mal sagen
können jetzt haben wir ein Ziel oder ein
Teilschritt unserer Strategie